on va plus loin avec zyad limam
directeur du mensuel afrique magazine
bonjour diallo soir face à vous bruno
daroux de la rédaction de france 24
rebonjour une re bonjour rafale le monde
fait face à un moment de péril ses mots
alarmant et son du secrétaire général de
l'onu antonio guterres est ce
aujourd'hui écouter
le temps de la retenue de la raison et
de la désescalade est arrivé il n'y a
plus de place pour des actes ou des
déclarations qui mènerait cette
situation dans les abysses
il est temps d'établir un cessez le feu
et de retourner sur le chemin du
dialogue et des négociations pour sauver
le peuple en ukraine et au delà de
l'accès aux
la réponse de la communauté
internationale à ces crimes doit être
décisive
immédiate et forte
l'ukraine accueille favorablement les
annonces d'hier et d'avant-hier sur les
sanctions contre la fédération russe
fait par l'union européenne les
etats-unis la grande-bretagne et le
canada
nous attendons d'autres sanctions plus
fortes
mais oui après antonio gutiérrez ou
venez d'entendre le président ukrainien
volodimir zelensky qui appelle à
davantage de sanctions face à la russie
qu'on dit sur le pied de guerre la
situation est critique même si pour
l'heure la russie n'a pas encore mis sa
menace à exécution
pas de mouvement de troupe pour venir en
aide aux séparatistes ukrainien même si
d'après les états unis 80% des troupes
russes seraient en position avancée
prête à passer à l'offensive bruno
daroux entre un maintien des lignes de
front dans le donbass en gros la
situation actuelle est gelée par les
accords de minsk dont vladimir poutine
dit lui même qu'ils sont aujourd'hui
caduc et une invasion totale de
l'ukraine quelles sont les options
possibles
à côté il ya plusieurs scénarios
possibles qui sont évidemment surveiller
de très près par tous les états majors
d'abord il faudra voir si les troupes
russes effectivement pénètre dans le don
de basse alors où l'on parle ce ne
serait pas encore le cas et les
américains ont des doutes quand même
donc si ses troupes qui sont qualifiés
de troupes de maintien de la paix
pénètre donc dans les deux républiques
autoproclamées
le premier scénario c'est qu'elle y
reste et qu' il ne se passe pas grand
chose finalement le deuxième scénario
c'est qu'elle ne cherche à conquérir le
reste du dans de basses qui est encore
aux mains de l'armée ukrainienne et là
il y aurait des premiers affrontements
et est reconnue désormais par vladimir
poutine c'est toute la nouveauté
vladimir poutine l'a déjà contrôlé lundi
là il a bien précisé la même parler de
frontières 1 il a bien précisé que lui
sa vision c'est une vision extensive du
dombass donc à peu près la moitié de la
région qui actuellement est encore tenue
par les ukrainiens et qui pourrait
également inclure plus au sud donc le
port stratégique de marioupol donc ça ce
serait le premier scénario où il y aura
un risque d'affrontement mais après tout
vladimir poutine puisqu'il parle de
frontières pour et estimé que une fois
cela réalisé il s'en tient là il ya un
deuxième scénario qui est en fait à
partir du nom de basse il ferait la
jonction jusqu'à la crimée créer une
forme de continuité territoriale avec la
ville de mario paul dont on parle notre
langue notamment la ville de marioupol
mais ensuite il pousserait vers la
crimée est donc là il y aurait puisque
ce sont des zones assez
russophone en fête est donc là il à
grandir est en fait son emprise sur
l'ukraine au bord de la mer d'azov
autour de la mer d'azov et puis même
certains disent ils pourraient pousser
plus à l'ouest de la crimée jusqu'à
odessa cercle à tout le sud et l'est de
l'ukraine seraient aux mains des troupes
russes ça paraît relativement
envisageable parce que ce sont des zones
où il ya le plus de russophones donc où
il y aurait le moins d'hostilité de la
part des populations voire un certain
accueil favorable de la part des
russophones et puis évidemment il ya le
scénario catastrophe c'est à dire une
invasion massive de l'ukraine avec des
opérations à partir de la biélorussie à
partir aussi du nord et de l'est là où
sont positionnées les troupes russes bon
en fait l'otan et les américains sont
très alarmiste on n'y croit pas vraiment
fait dans l'est dans les états majors on
n'exclut pas en revanche qu'il pourrait
y avoir des bombardements notamment y
compris de deux lieux stratégiques
autour de la capitale par exemple ça
c'est pas impossible voilà ce sont les
différents scénarios qui sont
actuellement sur la table zèle ni même
les ukrainiens ont temporisé en appelant
au calme la communauté internationale
notre correspondant à kiev qui est une
dizaine de minutes nous disait que
dorénavant ils sont effectivement
beaucoup plus inquiets et ils se
demandent si les prévisions des états
unis ne sont pas en réalité les bonnes
notamment sur ses troupes qui sera en
position avancée pour pour envahir quand
on sait que moscou a donné l'ordre
d'évacuer son personnel diplomatique de
kiev vous analysez ça comme en bas
d'abord il ya eu un discours il ya eu
une parole publique où le chef de l'état
russe a dit je nie l'existence de
l'ukraine c'est un non état n'a jamais
existé notre position c'est que c'est
nous qui l'avons fabriquer ces la russie
communiste qui l'a fabriqué qu'on est
frais et donc donc tout ce discours
qu'avait jamais été exprimée de cette
manière là avec les commentateurs ont
parlé d'un ton glacial d'une rancune de
d'une rancoeur d'une répétitivité dans a
donc on voit bien qu'il ya eu du côté
russe à la fois des intérêts
stratégiques c'est-à-dire de
limiter la progression de le temps de
créer ces fameux état tampon entre eux
et le reste de l'europe c'est des états
aussi qu'ils doivent être complètement
neutralisé c'est à dire faux faux faux à
atténuer toute pensée politique il faut
éviter pratiquement toute élection parce
qu'ils ont fait des élections on a des
résultats qui coïncide pas avec
l'objectif pratique qui les gens votent
pour un rapprochement vers vers l'ouest
donc c'est un problème et puis à cette
espèce de pathos très profond
visiblement au niveau du leadership en
tous les cas russe qui fait qu'on peut
s'inquiéter si on est ukrainien quand on
entend ça et puis il ya les troupes
disposer et puis les américains ont
montré qu'ils avaient de l'information
alors est-ce que c'était volontaire de
la donnée est ce que c'était une
tactique pauthe pour mettre la pression
sur les russes mais à chaque fois qu'ils
ont eu de l'information ils l'ont donné
ce qui est nouveau donc ça c'est
l'ensemble est forcément il ya une
amplitude et puis les scénarios dont
vous parliez des le scénario de la
situation humanitaire est catastrophique
parce que peut pas imaginer non plus que
les troupes russes sortirait de leur
enclave du dombass allait vers le sud
sans aucune résistance militaire
l'ukraine s'est pas un petit pays c'est
dans 4 4 me en mi temps c'est une
surface le long parler de la discussion
autour des russophones c'est une vraie
discussion là la carte du référendum est
d'ailleurs intéressante pour voir où il
n'y a pas eu de n'a pas eu de région qui
était foncièrement contre l'indépendance
donc
c'est une aventure militaire pour l'est
pour la russie qui engagent des risques
énormes de catastrophes politiques et
diplomatiques de peut-être difficulté
militaire de catastrophe humanitaire et
donc d'une certaine manière même le
régime doit calculer ses coûts parce que
faudrait pas que ça entraîne une
déstabilisation
non plus à moscou on connaît pas très
bien moi moi j'ai été stupéfaits par les
images d'un homme visiblement seul ou en
tous les cas qui apparaît seul au
pouvoir qui apparaît seul à prendre des
décisions on a du mal à croire que la
russie contemporaine soulier qu'un seul
homme qui puisse appuyer sur tous les
boutons le tsar absolue il est il est
forcément dans un jeu je pense de de
donnant donnant avec des forces
intérieures et sur lequel il lui même ne
peut pas prendre le risque de excusez
moi du terme de se casser la figure donc
c'est quand même une situation
extrêmement tôt fin sur un film et pour
tous les acteurs en fait avant la guerre
tout court en tout cas c'est la guerre
économique d'ores et déjà puisque des
sanctions ont été annoncées la russie
dit préparer une riposte forte et
douloureuse aux sanctions économiques
notamment américaines on a une idée de
la forme qu'elle pourrait prendre cette
riposte bruno daroux à écouter si pour
le moment ça la riposte n'a pas encore
eu lieu donc on va voir quels secteurs
vont être visés mais les américains
n'ont pas encore sorti non plus l'armé
fatale qui est swift a pour le moment
une longue on est au début et on est au
d en épargne soigneusement vladimir
poutine parce qu'on a pas moyen de le
toucher ou pas ça pourrait être une
riposte graduée l'affolement je ne suis
ni dans la terre ni dans celle de joe
biden en tout cas de joe biden il a
annoncé une gradation des sanctions à
chaque fois qui maintenant qu'il y aura
un mouvement des troupes russes il faut
quand même noter que les sanctions
européennes
cette fois ci vise quand même
l'entourage très proche de vladimir
poutine son chef de cabinet le ministre
de la défense le fameux le patro enfin
c'est pas le patron qui est fameux c'est
le groupe le patron du groupe wagner
donc la patronne de la télévision russia
today donc voilà il ya déjà des actions
ciblées est-ce que vladimir poutine va
faire la même chose en retour on sait
qu'en 2014 qui ont vu les options
européennes il avait frappé certains
secteurs certaines exportations
notamment alimentaires vers la russie ce
qui avait posé des problèmes par exemple
en france pour les éleveurs de porcs par
exemple ça avait été un gros problème
bon il a fait simplement cette annonce
on va attendre de voir s'il peut faire
des ripostes cible et ça paraît
compliqué des ripostes financière sa
part est également compliquée parce que
ça c'est plutôt contrôlé par les
américains donc il pourrait y avoir
peut-être d d d d embargo sur
l'exportation de certains produits et de
blé c'est et de blé ouais alors
vis-à-vis alors que les américains
vis-à-vis des européens à le blé ya le
gaz évidemment il pourrait couper le gaz
aussi et comme nous l'a l'europe est
déjà c'est compliqué tout ça j'ai le
nord stream c'est quand même très
spectaculaire la décision l'europe peut
se passer du du gaz russe et pour
combien de temps alors comme j'ai lu sur
twitter quelqu'un disait
l'europe peut s'en passer parce qu'elle
est riche donc elle a le temps de
réorganiser ses approvisionnements on a
évoqué le fait que ça poserait
d'ailleurs des questions intéressantes
sur le plan des relations de l'europe
avec d'autres partenaires je pense en
particulier à l'algérie son particulier
au qatar je pense à tous les gens qui
ont du gaz équipements feuillage aussi
la norvège donc disons que la norvège
étant dans le dans le dans le schéma
délire de les désaccords économique
européen met donc c'est clair il ya la
question du blé qui est une question
importante pas uniquement pour l'europe
mais voilà et puis c'est un c'est une
course encore une fois c'est la course
des uns contre les autres parce qu'
est-ce que la russie peut aussi soutenir
un siège économique sans vendre de gaz
sans vendre sont blessants c'est une
vraie quand on s'est détourné d'un
fournisseur il ya de fortes chances
qu'on y revienne pas par la suite oui
l'europe est dans une position
particulière parce que là on est en mode
sanctions on est en mode unitaire avec
les états unis on est en mode autant on
est en mode parce que le parce que le
danger parce que le danger est réel et
parce que les menaces russes sont réels
mais notre vérité à nous c'est qu'on est
leur voisin pour l'éternité et donc on
ne peut pas non plus tout balancer par
dessus bord on est obligé
de se penser à l'après même en se disant
comment après cette crise comment parce
que nous elle est la russie ce nous et
l'ukraine nous et la biélorussie mais
nous avec la moldavie aussi on n'en
parle pas mais les manipuler les
manoeuvres russe en moldavie pour
empêcher que le parti pro européen
prenne tout ça c'est notre environnement
et ce quitte ce qui nous a percutés en
fait c'est qu'on pensait que c'était
relativement stabilisée après la crimée
et voilà et d'un seul coup ça nous pète
à la figure aux etats unis quand on
parle avec les américains c'est déjà
certes ça remis la russie au centre d'un
agenda américain qui était complètement
orientée vers la chine mais y'a pas cela
se distendent ya parfois il n'y a pas ce
truc qui nous a pris nous ici parce que
c'est à nos portes quand même
oui absolument c'est nous c'est une
préoccupation territoriales et puis on
parle de la dépendance leur antre de la
faune à la haine à quelques minutes ise
sommes déterminés à sortir la dépendance
énergétique m'enfin en même temps plein
ce temps les y sont et l'allemagne
surtout l'allemagne zone très très
compliqué parce qu'elle s'est pas au
niveau des européens globalement c'est
40 % la dépendance au gaz russe de
l'allemagne c'est 55 % la france et 20%
envoyé l'an passé mais chacun voilà en
fait l'allemagne notamment est dans une
position très très compliqué et on va
sans doute en en parler demain puisque
un sommet extraordinaire est convoquée
entre les puissances européennes merci
ziadi ma merci également à bruno daroux
c'était on va plus loin